you remember in the Lion King you may
not remember when when when moffat
Mufasa that's the King right goes and
takes Simba up to show him his territory
he says he is the king of everything
that the light touches and that's a very
old idea and you guys had no problem
with you know that was fine that made
sense and that I would be on the light
was the darkness and that was the
elephant graveyard that was death that
was the place of death and danger that's
where the hyenas hung out and you
weren't supposed to go there and so of
course Simba because he's a rule
breaking hero just like Harry Potter
immediately goes there and so you know
that's like the forbidden fruit it's the
same sort of idea if you want someone to
do something the best thing to do is
tell them that they shouldn't and not
explain why you know so for example if I
said to you at the beginning of this
class look I've got one rule here don't
sit in that chair no matter what you'd
be thinking the whole year especially if
I reminded you well just what's up with
that chair like let's chair as magical
all of a sudden you some of you might
even well you probably wouldn't because
this is a ridiculous example but maybe
you know you come to class early and sit
in that chair just to see what would
happen you know and people are very
curious and that's exactly what we're
like and that's a very old story too
right it's like opening Pandora's box
don't open that box you'll be sorry it's
like oh huh you know all the horrors of
the world fly out and believe me you
will open Pandora's box many times in
your life because you know with your
family or maybe your mate or maybe your
children you'll have this idea that they
have a box with things in it that you
want to know about and you'll say well
I'm kind of curious about this
particular event so why don't you tell
me about it and they say well no we
probably really shouldn't open that box
and you keep bugging him and then they
open it and then all sorts of things fly
out that you didn't expect and then
maybe you think hey it would have been
better if I would have just left that
damn box closed but and you can do the
same thing to yourself believe me
and so the Pandora's Box idea the
forbidden
root idea that's that's a major-league
idea and part of the reason in the
judeo-christian tradition why people are
saddled with the notion of original sin
is because hyper cortically developed
chimpanzees without much sense can't
keep their hands off things and so they
keep exploring even when they know
better and every time they do that they
learn something that is that destroys
the paradise that they currently inhabit
right because there's plenty uni and I
never learned anything in your life
that's of importance without it having a
pretty damn destabilizing effect on you
at the moment of realisation right you
learn something happy it's like whatever
you know that all that means is that I
was doing things right like it's nice
and everything but it's not informative
you do something and all hell breaks
loose that'll make you think now it's
for sure you might never stop thinking
for the rest of your life